i don't want to give up but i will not
give into coercion
we want to be midwives but we can't this
isn't an ordinary vaccine protest many
of the thousands here are nhs workers
many could soon lose their jobs
like carl who's been a nurse for more
than a decade yeah i will in uh if it
continues we'll be out of a job on the
1st of april yes would you describe
yourself as an anti-vaxxer no i wouldn't
i've had every other vaccine up until
this point a lot of my colleagues are in
the same boat and
they're potentially losing livelihoods
and jobs and food on the table
um when they when we've been working
through the pandemic the rules are that
to keep their jobs front line nhs
need to have two jabs by april that
means they need to get their first dose
in february two weeks from now and that
is why you see the real urgency here
today
and beyond protest politicians are
uneasy too we saw a lot of people vote
against it before um christmas i think
that number would be rising as we come
to the crunch and we see that actually
there's still a lot of people who
haven't been vaccinated do we really
want to see these big crises that could
be caused in certain parts of the
country because all of a sudden a whole
lot of people are not on the front line
simply because they haven't had this
vaccination last week the prime minister
said the government will reflect on the
way ahead
any pain or swelling just take some
paracetamol for 24-48 hours but reports
of a pause to the policy have today been
dismissed as a royal college of gps call
for a delay in a debate not just about
ethics but logistics with warnings as
many as 70 000 nhs staff could lose
their jobs
so mandatory vaccination is a government
policy but as healthcare professionals
we all have a duty to make sure that we
are protected to make sure that our
colleagues and our patients are
protected so i know that our teams will
be doing everything they can to continue
to have vaccine confidence building
conversations and offering that
all-important vaccination to staff who
are yet to have their first second or
their booster dose
it's a policy that stirred debate and
emotion too
a prime minister keen to cling on to his
own job we'll have to think carefully
about so many health workers losing
theirs ali fortescue's